unfortunately we didn't have enough time
to show all the comedy we produce for
our comic-con shows that included a set
of tips that our prop master built Oh
made to help people save money on their
comic-con cosplay costumes now now that
comic-con is over I thought it just
doesn't make any sense to show them here
in LA I've been told that built all
vehemently disagrees let's get him out
here and find out what his opinion is
our prop master built Oh would you give
it up for him please
yeah you go no go ahead say what you
gotta say Yeah right
sorry I wasn't cool enough for your
Comic Con comedy crap alright we'll bill
very articulate bill we ran out of time
we just didn't have the time [ __ ] I
wrote them I shot them boom roll tape
put some Krazy Glue on a spoon stick it
to your hand
boom magneto there's more just you axe
[Music]
put on an I'm with stupid t-shirt cross
off everything but the s boom Superman
[Applause]
[Music]
don't cut your fingernails for three
years
Oh Wolverine why didn't you shave that
makes Lucy take a heated waffle iron
push your face into it
boom spider-man
better in the crap you show down there
[Applause]
take a hammer be incredibly handsome
boom
Thor next tell the cameraman to go
really far back come on come on the last
one
take one viagra boom the force awakens
hey thanks for watching please subscribe
to my youtube channel so they will stop
making me shoot these videos please